we ran a stack turn Norway this man is  getting up close and personal with the  local wildlife this is unfortunate  this guy has found himself in the wrong  place at the wrong time the bird is a  male Capra Kelly which is a large  species of grouse and the reason it's  attacked this guy is because it's mating  season this guy's actually walked into  what's called a breeding lek which is a  special territory that males hold in the  hopes of attracting females this was  filmed early in the morning which is  unfortunate timing because this is when  the male kappa Kelly do their mating  display they do it that time of day  because the cooler drier air means the  sound will travel further so if you'd  like to watch Capra Kelly's you're  better off waiting until the afternoon